how are you feeling what are you
enjoying most about this journey uh
Donuts so far that was the first time
around but for baby number two Rihanna's
got a different pregnancy craving yeah
and experience the students would be
mommy of two shared her Feast on
Instagram posting not one but two plates
of pasta with her baby bump on full
display yummy and it's been quite the
ride for Riri who's having a big year
not only did she perform at the Oscars
she also made an epic statement during
the Super Bowl halftime show
that's re revealing she's expecting baby
number two with boyfriend ASAP Rocky it
really feels Like A lot's happening all
at once it feels like motherhood
Oscars Super Bowl I'm still pinching
myself really I'm grateful I'm grateful
and since welcoming her little man last
year whose name has yet to be revealed
she shared little glimpses with fans on
social media you are making it look so
stylish you haven't
well you have to right see that I mean
so it's a long nine or ten months girl
you know you you have to enjoy it you
were making it your fashion show I love
I'm trying to enjoy it as much as I
could and fashion is one of my favorite
things so you know redefining what it
means to even be pregnant and maternal
you know it always it it can get
uncomfortable at times so you know you
can dress the part and pretend baby
number two is expected sometime this
summer and her baby boy turns one in May
cool
and no big deal on the cover of British
Vogue You are a mama big congratulations
[Music]
you start talking mad weird when it's
about to start talking do you like it I
know what is the best part about
motherhood right now again oh my God the
morning's just like seeing his morning
face yeah and you know like seeing a
baby with like little bags and waking up
and they're just like startled they're
trying to figure out where they at is
the cutest it's my favorite part of the
day the mornings that's like I I cherish
that you singing to the little one oh
yeah oh my God the craziest stuff like
I've been making up just freestyle
making up that new lullaby album right
oh
foreign